well we both have been in therapy CBS
has paid for both of us too you know
they wanted us both healthy and safe
this was traumatic for both of us it was
ugly
when I came out of that game I I believe
I even said somebody shoot me I probably
sent all the red flags up that I was
going to kill myself over those which of
course I you know I would never do that
as much as I felt like I probably
deserved it but um they there was a
psychologist outside the path I walked
down I fell into her arms and she was
just great for me with day for days and
my boyfriend's been wonderful to me he's
been by my side through the whole
process and you know with having to live
with it and not talk about it for so
long almost ten months now is traumatic
in itself you know part of getting past
traumas being able to make yourself
vulnerable and deal with it and talk
through it and it's been a difficult
situation this aired last night it was
impossible to watch but I feel like now
the healing can begin not only for me
but hopefully for Zeke and hopefully for
trans people across the world I just my
message to them is I know that it's
frustrating to have somebody like me out
here talking about this it's not fair
I'm not the voice that should be out
here I'm not the person that should be
doing this your voice should be here but
while I am here let me just say that
trans people are wonderful and they're
courageous and we should be elevating
their humanity and highlighting their
dignity and raising their voices to
where you can get to know who they are
these are not the awful hateful people
that the bigots in the world wants you
to think I'm in Greensboro North
Carolina right now North Carolina is
ground zero for this stuff and it's just
the bigots in our in our General
Assembly who are trying to pass all
these laws you know this stuff that it's
not about bathrooms it's about erasing
trans people out of society whether or
not they have the right to exist